We're now going to take a look at the individual settings for each of the various options
you're going to find in the groom tool.
And the first one we're going to start off with is the LOD or level of detail.
Now this panel controls the decimation of the groom's individual levels of detail.
What that basically means is that by adding different level of details, we can reduce
the size of the groom assets so that when it's viewed further away from the camera,
it's going to consume less resources.
And to set this up, it's actually quite easy.
All we need to do is just press this plus right here and this will add a level of detail.
From the level of details, we can then select the geometry type, binding type, and simulation
and RBF interpolation options.
And to do this in the editor, let's just pop over there really quick.
So this is really simple to do.
I'm actually going to delete that existing one that I have there.
And then I'm just going to press this plus sign right here and you can see it added
the level of detail.
Now notice that the curves here at level of detail zero are at 67,000 and 2.5 million
points.
Then if we look at the level of detail one, we have 33,000 and 1.7, so you can see
it is going down in size.
And then all we need to do now and our level of detail is determine whether we want
to use strands, cards, or meshes.
The binding type, whether we're going to have a rigid, which is going to not move.
And this would be really good for something that's really, really far away.
It's going to help reduce the resources that are needed to simulate this.
Or we could take our RBF interpolation and we also enable that or disable it.
And again, these are all things that are going to make this run faster, but reduce
the complexity of the groom and not make it look as realistic.
So we'd want to do this on things that are very, very far away from the camera.
As for the amount of level of details to add, I always like to error on less is more.
So definitely having one or two level of details should be something you should try
to achieve.
Having more level of details than that is going to be a per project situation.
And as always, you should test to make sure adding level of details is giving you the
performance benefits and gains that you want.
The next tool that we're going to talk about is interpolation of the interpolation panel
modifies some of the properties set during the initial import of the groom.
From here, you can reduce the number of curves and vertices your groom is made
up of, and you can also adjust the quality of the interpolation from point to point.
Now, a couple of things to note here.
If you are going to look to improve the performance of your groom, you're going to
want to reduce or decrease the interpolation quality and interpolation distance.
This will allow the groom to use less memory, but might introduce artifacts when the groom
is moving, increasing this or leaving it at the highest value is going to make your
groom look more realistic, but increase the amount of memory required for your groom.
One of the other things to note here, too, is that when you are dealing with super
long hair, you are going to want to keep these as high as you can, or else you will
introduce artifacts to the rendering.
So if I pop back over here to our editor real quick, and inside of our interpolation
here, we can do something like I could make this say very low and turn the curve
decimation settings here.
Bring this down very, very low here.
I should just set this like 0.5 by say like 0.5.
And we are really bringing down the quality here of this particular groom, but it is going
to run a little bit faster when used inside of the project.
So just keep that in mind that the interpolation is controlling how that hair is going to
interact when it's moving.
And we can reduce this setting to give us back more performance.
But it's going to make the hair look a little less realistic, increasing this or keeping
it at the highest settings is going to give us more realistic looking groom, but at the cost
of memory and performance.
The strands tool allows us to control various rendering properties related to the
strands geometry of our groom.
From here, we can set our material and we can also change key properties of the strands
of the hair, such as its width, root and tip scale, and enable things such as
ray tracing and other rendering features for our groom to better assist with its rendering.
Let's pop over to the editor and take a look at this tool now.
So here we are on our strands.
We do have the ability also to apply a material here.
Now, note, if your material has not been set up to be used with hair, it will not be
applied here. And we'll cover that in a few slides.
The other things we can do here is we can adjust things like our hair width.
We can make the hair a little bit long or a little bit wider or shorter.
We can also do things like reduce the hair here.
Not five. I want to do point five.
You can see here if I do it to like point one point, yeah, point zero one.
There we go. We've actually really reduced that.
It's not as full as it was before.
Let me just do this here so we can get back to normal.
Then we can do things like our stable razzle, stable rasterization, scatter our scene
lighting or use hair ray tracing geometry if we're utilizing ray tracing.
So again, these are all features that deal with the lighting or the density of our
particular strands that we're using.
The cards section of the groom tools panel is where you set up any cards,
geometry and their accompanying textures.
Cards are ways to reduce your groom's complexity by replacing the strands with
mesh cards that can either be created in a DCC or imported to use the cards tool.
I'm going to pop over to the editor now.
The first thing we're going to need to do is add a card asset by pressing the
white plus icon right here.
Once we've done that, we will then have the ability to change the material
that's associated with the cards.
Their guide type, whether they are generated or based off of a guide, and
then the cards mesh that we want to use.
And then underneath that, we also have the various textures that can be
associated with our cards.
We can have multiple levels of cards by simply adding additional card assets.
So this could be, you know, we could have a card for a LOD group, say one,
and then add an additional one for two and so on.
Cards are a great way to reduce the rendering requirements for your groom
assets when they're utilized far off in the distance.
And if you are looking for ways to improve groom's performance, especially
for real time projects, adding cards is super beneficial as it will help reduce
the complexity of your groom at meshes and still maintain that look and feel of
the groom strands working and having physics applied to them.
The next tool we're going to talk about is meshes.
Now meshes allows us to add mesh based geometry for used in the LODs
of a groom asset.
This is different than what we might have done for cards where cards would
be strands of cards or 2D planes that give us the illusion of our hair.
In this particular part of the tool, we'd actually be dealing with an
actual mesh that simulates the hair.
So let's go ahead and pop over here into the editor really quick.
We'll click on meshes.
Now to use this like we did with the rest of our tools, we would
need to add a mesh assets.
We'd hit the plus sign right there, and then we would just simply apply
our material and our imported texture, or I'm sorry, our imported mesh.
We would then utilize the textures here to find any textures that we want.
And then the LOD index to define the level of detail that we wish for
this mesh to replace.
So in a general setup, what we would have is most likely level of detail
zero would be our standard groom asset.
And then level of detail one would be our cards.
And then level of detail two would be our meshes.
And that's generally how we would think about applying level of details or
utilizing these particular tools together.
The materials tool and the groom tool settings allows us to add and
define which materials will be used for various parts of our groom.
Let's pop over to the engine to take a look at how to use this tool as
explaining it might not necessarily show you how cool this actually can be.
So what we can do with this is under our materials here, we'll press this
plus sign, and then we'll give this slot name a new name like Strands.
And then we'll do this one more time, and we'll call this one cards.
And then we will do this one more time, and we'll call this one mesh or meshes.
And notice that I'm matching these strands, cards and meshes, because what I can do
now is assign a material here for what is going to be used on the strands,
what's going to be used on the cards and what's going to be used on the meshes.
And then when I come into the individual strands for the material here,
I can select these strands for the cards.
I could select the cards and then for our mesh here, I could select our meshes.
And that way I have full control over which materials will be applied to which
meshes, strands or cards inside of the groom asset.
And this is really, really helpful because it means that if I do to make any
types of changes, I can do it from one centralized location instead of having
to go to the strands, cards and meshes to make any changes that I might need to make.
This is just an easier and more precise way to make those changes.
Should we need to make any.
The last tool we're going to talk about in the groom tools setting is the binding tool.
And this just simply shows you the binding asset that is utilized in this
particular room. You can use the icon
highlighted here to view the binding asset.
And that's pretty much all that this tool is used for.
So not a lot to cover in it.
The last tool that we're going to talk
about in the groom tool settings is the binding tool.
Now, the bindings are just simply an asset that binds your groom asset to a
particular skeletal mesh, and all this particular tool does is just show you
that binding asset.
The icon, which you can see right here,
can be used to browse the groom binding inside of the content browser,
and that's pretty much all that this tool is used for.
With that out of the way,
we have wrapped up our groom tool explanations and we're now going to go
into the next section, taking a look at creating groom materials.